(funky music)
- So the only people who
actually use Groupons are old,
so I'm checking in with
some senior citizens
to see what they were Grouponing in 2011.
- I really regret being part of this now.
- I really started using Groupon
about a year and a half ago.
- It's almost trendy again,
you're kind of like a hipster.
- Yeah, exactly. I'm bringing it back.
- You're bringing it back because
it definitely isn't cool right now.
- No.
- So Allison, back in
2012 you got yourself
a 60 minute Swedish
massage from Bodis Spa.
What could have been stressing
you out so much in 2012?
Did you crack your iPhone 3s screen?
- My wife's birthday was coming up,
so we went to what was called
"Pirate's Dinner Adventure,"
but here's the thing--
- I (stutters)
- This was vampirates. So
basically that means replace rum,
like yo ho ho in bottle, with blood.
- So your first Groupon expired in 2011.
I mean back then Barak
Obama was on his first term,
he wasn't even running for reelection.
This is like dinosaurs were
walking the earth back then.
- No I got laser hair removal. (laughs)
- Where?
(laughter)
- I don't wanna say! (laughs)
- Just tell me when to stop
when I get to the right place.
You got a Groupon for Quiznos?
- Ha!
- I feel like that's kind
of ridiculous, this is 2011.
- (laughs)
- I was still in college.
I couldn't even drink back then,
and you were Grouponing Quiznos.
- Look what a good deal that is!
- [Guy] You saved six dollars.
- [Girl] I saved six dollars!
- For Quiznos that's a whole sandwich!
- I was a broke college student then
and I wouldn't even buy
six dollar Quiznos Groupon.
This is ridiculous.
- I think the point of Groupon is
so you buy more things,
and then they'll expire,
and then the place just
gets the money back
from having to give you a free service.
- Just walk in with your game face
and be like "I'm getting
this couple's massage."
- Sometimes I would buy one
and I wouldn't actually use it,
and I'm like "What am I doing here?"
- That's called wasteful spending,
and it's something that
Republicans and Democrats
agree we should cut back on.
- Well, I agree too. That's
why I stopped using it.
- Cool.
(upbeat music)